we can have a nice afternoon together
and if you didn't expect webassembly
you're probably in the wrong room so we
do some webassembly today we will
probably not be like very in-depth on
like how a for loop would be transpired
down to almost assembly code or
something we will look at it from a more
use case specific point of view so we
will do some actual use cases with
webassembly today together we will use
some rust and some Seba I'll get into
that right afterwards first let me
quickly introduce myself so my name is
Patrick I am from Switzerland there are
some guys from Switzerland here right
yeah from my own company hello I started
programming back in 2005 I did an
apprenticeship I stumbled kinda into PHP
I didn't know at the time what
programming was so there was the thing
called PHP somebody on Stack Overflow
told me put it on your inner file and
put it on a server and then it will just
run and actually it did that so I was
quite fascinated at that time and later
on wanted to do something in the
front-end right so now when the user
clicks something something should happen
that would be nice so I stumbled into
JavaScript with jQuery how to support ie
ie 5.5 and 6 at that time were nice
times yeah so if I think about our
browser problems today they're much
nicer than they were back then right so
everybody who had to support ie 5 to 5 6
knows what I'm probably talking about
right yes so I have grown to become or I
became a Charma script enthusiast
yeh I do work for a company called suka
sorry for these funny dots under you
that's just the chairman language right
so that's the last name of the guy I
founded the company so we are a Swiss
based company we were founded in 1968
and we do mostly software consulting and
business like agile business
transformation
we started off in Switzerland but
nowadays we are kind of global we are
operating in 8 countries so don't worry
if you can't read the names so the
basics are we are in middle Europe or
Central Europe it's cold right a bit of
Eastern Europe and three years ago we
started right here sukkah Asia that's
why we are here today or why I had the
opportunity from a company to come
actually here to Asia which is very cool
so we have suka Singapore we started two
years ago with zero people right and now
we are at 36 in place so we are growing
quite fast which is very cool and
actually we want to grow more so we
would like to reach a target of 100
employees at the end of next year let's
see if we can reach our goal there's
also silk your Hong Kong which is a bit
smaller it's still a bit a bit fresh so
it's one and a half years ago when it
was founded and it's currently at 20
employees so it's smaller than here but
still still a nice little team so if
you're interested if you want to know
more about what we do and how we do it
and where we are all from we are these
guys with their shirts now if you took
one you have one of these shirts too now
right but the guys that wear it now
where are they
behind back there all these guys are
working and girls sorry are working for
silica if you have any questions if you
want to get in touch with us just come
talk to us we actually like to talk so
but now guess let's get into it oops
voila so our goals today are that we can
all kind of say what is webassembly all
about how can i how can I achieve new
native performance in the browser how do
I send the code to the browser how do I
interact with it that's that's basically
the most important part so how can I
send data back and forth between my
JavaScript and my C Java rust go
whatever language codes I want to have
running in webassembly
and in the end we're all still gonna
have some fun like do some exercises
that you can just fool around a bit and
see what it's actually capable of that's
basically the schedule around here I
thought we might want to have like two
minor breaks so we are not completely
down in here and we can get some oxygen
from from the outside we will first look
at some basics a bit of theory and then
we will get into our first exercises and
then we will have a look into more
in-depth use cases so how does it really
really work if we're gonna pass strings
if we want to work with 64-bit integers
and stuff like that and in the end we'll
have a experimenting exercise with
OpenCV I will explain that a bit in a
second
exactly so if you wonder if you never
have seen that this kind of presentation
is with the framework reveal.js I guess
most of you have already seen that I
think a lot of speakers actually used
that here at the conference so you might
not be that new to you so let's jump
right into him yeah what is web assembly
so from now on I probably gonna call it
often buzzin because it's shorter than
web assembly but it means the same thing
we will see Rosen throughout the whole
workshop so don't get it I hope it don't
get you confused or something the cool
thing is why web assembly also really
took off in the last couple of months or
years is because browser support has to
has increased a lot so you see like
maybe two years ago you would have to
start Chrome with certain flags that web
assembly is actually available to you
but nowadays it's readily available in
all the browsers that you actually want
to use obviously since I 11 is not being
actively developed anymore right I 11
constantly about H Safari Firefox Chrome
they all have a good implementation of
web assembly 1.0 we will talk a bit
about that what is what is going to come
in the next couple of months
or years so this is the first
webassembly version so what is was an
apps actually so so what do we have to
think of when we talk about webassembly
basically it's bytecode for the browser
right we can we can actually send a
binary to the browser and it will run in
a VM with near native performance so
whatever we can compile to that format
will be able to run in the browser right
away no need for any backends no need
for any other calls you get your binary
you tell the brand I should run that in
that web assembly VM and it will just
just work we will see that later on it's
actually a first I think or one of the
first times that all the browser vendors
including Apple were really able to sit
at the table and say this is the format
we all support our no prefixes there's
nothing else in it so they really all
have the same VM well the same
implementation of it that's really cool
in my opinion
but you might ask what languages can
actually be compiled to a samurai can I
use Java can I use go language so I
included a list of or a github
repository where somebody actually
curated or is has a curated list of
languages that are supported currently
so this is basically just a list of
languages that have a compiler that can
compile to the yasm so you see here
there are hatched eggs or hatched
chickens and eggs so the ones with the X
they are not there yet but the ones with
the hatched chickens are very good
supported so you see the C language is
like C and C++ they are very good
supported we have go which is good
supported we have Lua and I think
brainfuck right so if you want to write
brainfuck go ahead and rust that's
actually what we will be using a bit
throughout this workshop don't worry if
you don't know rust that well you don't
need any in-depth knowledge so we will
have very basic small functions in web
assembly and fool around with them right
so you don't have to know how the memory
management of rust actually works how
all the details of all the types are we
will just have a very basic set so don't
worry about that I hope it will be will
not be overwhelming at all so let's look
at a small compilation example that we
have kind of understands what happens
behind the scenes so this is a little C
code can you all see that is to contrast
okay enough is it good okay so this is a
little C function that does factorial
right you probably all know that if we
make if you have the factorial of 5 you
would multiply 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1 which would then be hundred and
20 so a very easy function that is
recursive so we call ourselves with n
minus 1 or yeah n minus 1 so we would
first compile that in an intermediate
format so
from there it will be easier to compile
it to actual webassembly
so you still see some of you might be a
bit more familiar with code like that so
you can kinda figure out what that would
do or maybe you can at least kind of
draw some some lines between here and
the C code we saw before right you might
think like okay I see kind of there is
the integer and we do something with
that and in the end it will look like
that so obviously we are all able to
read that right away right we are
programmers so we just see that like the
matrix and we see oh yeah obviously this
is factorial yeah no I just wanted you
to show this is the actual format that
will be sent over the line so that you
saw it there's also a text
representation of that whole thing so
this is what it looks like when we are
using the IDE later on when we will
program a bit if you click on the bottom
binary you will see that code actually
this is not what will be sent to the
browser this is just the format for us
that we can actually read at least to a
certain extent right you can kinda see
what's happening so what we actually do
here this is but this is not what we
will send to the browser we will
actually send a binary to the browser
not this string representation this is
just for us so we can see the bit or we
can at least least read it a bit so
let's come to the limitations right so
we have seen we can compile cool so can
we compile anything does this everything
where to do we have like any native
function you could think about
unfortunately no so let's first talk
about memory memory management is a huge
thing right we probably all struggled
with it once at least what web assembly
has is flat linear memory if if that
doesn't really ring a bell with you this
means pretty much you have one array and
every element of the array is one byte
so if you would have one kilobyte of
memory you will have a array with 1024
elements every element would be one byte
so fairly easy right you can just
navigate on that array if you
wanna do some pointer magic you can just
increase and decrease your pointer and
read any byte that you wanna have until
you get some out of memory exception or
index out of bounds exception what it
doesn't happen this is a very important
thing this is also why you saw Java is
not quite there yet it's not a hatch
deck it's still kind of in that
breathing State
we don't have garbage collection so this
means we we have a memory array and if
you are with C or C++ you are you're you
sit right you free your own memory so
that works but languages that use
garbage collection don't work out of the
box so that's a big thing we will talk
about later but it's working progress I
will come to that point so if you
thought like you can send a binary to
the browser and they can just run as a
whole web application as of now this is
not really the case we don't have access
to all the browser stuff so for example
Dom is missing so if we have our C
program we can't go like document query
element and then we will just get the
Dom node currently this is not supported
but this is one of the bigger issues
that is being discussed and is proposed
for one of the upcoming upcoming
versions of Basel then this is a this is
quite a high limitation if you want to
do a lot of hardcore computing where you
want to have the leverage of the GPU so
you can actually be fast or how fast
math currently there is no cheap you
access and it's not really planned
because it's a very hard discussion
there is so much to discuss about how
you actually access the different
graphics cards with all their different
architectures and different programming
languages so this is something that is
being discussed but it's not like as a
big priority currently so I'm sorry if
you want to have your blockchain miner
in the browser not yet unfortunately
because CPU mining is not that good
right but also what's maybe a bit of a
better actual use case that we have
heavy machine learning is often done on
that
pure so you can't do that right now so
when we do machine learning stuff we are
limited to CPU CPU calculations then one
of the biggest limitations that we will
stumble across right from the beginning
is there aren't many types in web
assembly that doesn't mean like your C
code can't use all its types right C can
use any type it wants I mean it has
direct memory access it just does what
it wants but the interface between
browsers and web assembly basically has
these four types or these five types we
have integers 32 and 64 bits we have
floats 32 and 64 bits and real functions
but this is pretty much all we have - we
have on earth that we can actually use
for the first couple of exercises we
will basically be sending integers forth
and back so that's kind of a limitation
but this is being worked on - so what we
do when we want to exchange other types
so we are back to pointer arithmetic
right so what we would do is if we take
a rust example we would allocate memory
for a string and rust would write that
string into that memory then take the
pointer the pointer is an integer right
so we send that integer through the
interface get it to JavaScript
JavaScript on its side has access from
the from from above right to the
webassembly memory so what it does is it
takes a pointer goes into that array
reach the string until the first 0
because C strings for example are 0
null-terminated so it reads until it
finds the first 0 thus interpret every
byte as a utf-8 byte and voila we have
our string in JavaScript it's not very
cool but we will do it later on so you
will see how it does so this is what we
kind of have to deal with now but we
will see that light source oh don't
worry about it too much
but what is coming right we want to know
okay these are the limitations for what
should be coming and one of the first
things is also the first things I
mentioned at the limitations actually
since garbage collection is not
supported right now all the languages
that use a garbage collector can I have
to do their own garbage collector then
compile it down tourism and then send it
with your actual binary to the browser
so the browser instantiates you're
welcome code plus that sent garbage
collector that will then work in web
assembly so Russ does it that way for
example obviously not very good for
binary size and and the whole efficiency
so what they are working on now is that
you have some basic garbage collection
in web assembly right away so you don't
have to send your own garbage collector
we don't want to be writing our own
garbage collectors right then another
big thing is host bindings this is
actually cool so this would mean we can
actually take Tom notes sent them to web
assembly or even create the web assembly
at the dom nodes in webassembly sent
them forth and back transform them
update and delete them so the host
bindings proposal is very cool and would
actually allow us to do a lot of things
then what I didn't mention with the
limitations multi-threading so threats
should be coming soon what they were
thinking is that you can have an
abstraction over threads so not every
browser has to deal with every or your
web assembly code doesn't have to deal
with on which operating system it runs
right and which way it does create a
threat so what they were thinking is you
already have threads in the web with web
workers right so you can already kind of
have threats so they would leverage what
is existing and would take that to web
assembly so you can actually have
threats in the form or in the same way
that web workers will work or kind of
the same way
exactly the same way then one of the
biggest problems I think everybody
everyone in here has struggled with that
right exception happening every language
has its own concept we have a lot of
various exception handling mechanisms
and we will see that later on whether
assembly doesn't have one yet
so if you see code fails this can be
very hard to debug and kind of find out
what actually happened because the
exception is not like going up to
JavaScript then we can just have a
try-catch around it this is not working
currently but it should be in probably
more of the far future I would say
because if you go to the github
repository or web assembly and follow
that issue you will see there's a lot of
discussions and this goes way beyond
whether I understand so I don't even try
to explain that to you here reference
types is very closely coupled to the
host bindings approach so this would
mean that we actually leverage that
interface to have that any ref type so
we can pass in various kind of types and
references this would be closely coupled
to the house binding so both of them
would kind of be have to be solved for
it to work properly and to a cool extent
and that's a lot more so there's a cool
list of that I think where is it oh yeah
the guy Colin Everhart he has a very
goodness about that if you're gonna have
a look at that he has really every
proposal there is in which phase it is
what he thinks about it what he thinks
is the actual hard part about it so if
you want to read more about that and you
want to really go into all the details
all the nitty-gritty details check that
out really cool blog post in my opinion
you will have access to my presentation
later on so you will have all these
links cool
so that's it very short a brief
introduction to webassembly the theory
before we go into our first exercises so
do you have any questions at that moment
still feeling okay ish retired from
lunch probably right cool so let's move
on let's go let's go to the actual
exercises the fun stuff right cool where
are we here we are so let's try out the
basics of web assembly what I just kind
of talked about we want to build and run
some code that's what we are here for at
least I hope that's what you are here
for right so we're going to take rust
for for a minute so I will do probably
the shortest rust introduction you will
ever get and it will not be in any way
even closely to be complete so we'll
just look at a very very easy function
declaration this one fairly easy
function I think what it does everybody
of you see what it does it adds one to a
given integer so this is hardcore math
right we will be so fast with that and
JavaScript would be so slow with that no
obviously not
but let's look at the rest function so
what is it so the first thing we notice
is that little flag up at the at the top
of our function
it says no mangle I hope you can all
read that from the contrast what it does
is basically just tell the compiler hey
please don't change the name of that
function and don't remove it because you
see that nobody actually calls it right
if you would use the rust compiler
without that he would just remove the
function and the binary would get his
zero bytes because he says yeah you
don't call that function so I'm gonna
optimize it away
good job so with no mangle we can
actually tell the compiler please don't
do that we need to be able to call that
function by name so change the name
please don't change the name and please
don't remove it because yeah so which
public extern see we say rust that this
function will be called from externally
and it will be called by AC like
language
so what Russ does is make sure that a CE
compiled language can actually call that
external function and this is what we
will have when we call it over the web
assembly interface you would actually
not have to write that C that's kind of
the default of rust but I did include it
here so you have the whole example so
you see what's actually going on so this
is the function declaration I think
that's actually pretty similar to what
you would see with typescript or maybe
you are used to CoffeeScript or
something the only thing that you see
here is the 32-bit integer so we get one
parameter in called X and we will return
one 32-bit integer I think simple right
and this is the actual block the actual
function so what do you notice here
there is no return statement if you want
to you can always add a return but rust
doesn't need you to rust will just
return the last expression you have in
your block so if you're feeling lazy
today yesterday you don't need
semicolons
you don't need return statements with
rust if you want to do them either way
they will not hurt you so whatever you
like cool but since I don't want you to
have to install the rust compiler right
we have Linux Mac OS windows certainly
what would work on some of the machines
and the Sun we would just have some
weird issues I'm gonna use the web
assembly studio an awesome project by
the Mozilla group or a Mozilla company
it is an online either IDE that allows
us to actually write rust or C or I
think there's weather some assembly
script but we are going to use rust
today so we can write our code in there
and directly compile and run it from
there which is amazing in my opinion so
if I can ask you all to try to go to
that URL when I tried it last time
somebody was trying it with H and it
wasn't working with H I should work with
Firefox Safari and Chrome so I
hope there's nobody like wanting to hard
car use edge so you can try it
yeah is everybody in the Wi-Fi the Wi-Fi
password would be over there otherwise
so La Salle chairs comes with the Wi-Fi
and choice confession would be the
password
when you go in there you will get that
little assistant over here please select
the simple roast project the empty rust
project we will go step by step until we
kind of reached at lower hello world
rust project please don't open that yet
but because it will have pretty much
everything in there but we will kind of
try to go step by step until we kind of
until we finally understand what the
hello world project actually does so
please go into the empty Russ project
and let's see what we have there since I
want to try to come code a bit to here I
have to do it like that okay so if you
open the empty Russ project you will see
that source folder over here here are
the three files that we are actually
interested in the HTML Javascript and
the rust so first of all if you go to
the rust file you will see that this is
absolutely one-to-one the function that
we just looked at right so nothing too
fancy here you have just heard about
that function cool
if you click build up here like there's
a build command if you hit that you will
see there is a output on the bottom task
field is running and then build complete
what you will notice is now you have an
out folder and there's the myosin file
so this is our binary as mentioned
before if you click on that you will
actually see these s expressions that we
were talking about earlier if you really
want to watch or I want to take a look
at the binary you can right click on
that file name and somewhere down here
you
have view as binary and this helps us a
lot right cool but if you want to look
at it this is what actually will be sent
to the browser just so you know this is
not the real format nice but we see here
we have a function that is exported
called add one and there's some inter
232 param and the results that is
integer 32 so what we would expect right
nothing too fancy around here so let's
look at the Java Script what do we need
to actually get that running and I will
be reformatting that quickly a little
bit so it's easier to read for us or at
least I hope it is easier to read for us
so let's have a look at that yeah is it
big enough do you can you read it
otherwise just scream and say cool I
hope everybody in here knows fetch right
so we just fetch a file out main Razzles
so this is it right
we know that file then what we do is we
create an array buffer out of it and
that will be handed directly to web
assembly so if you go to your browser
console nowadays you will see you have
that webassembly object right on your
window object so every browser nowadays
hasa you can just use it like that what
we can do is we take this array of bytes
and instantiate the web assembly
instance out of it cool a promise and it
will return us this result on that
results we have the instance and this is
finally finally our Bassem interface
right so here we are you see over here
there's an expert's on that object so
this is where all the exporter functions
of our bottom of our running lesson will
be located at and as you probably
guessed right we are going to call that
one function yeah what we're going to do
is we expect there to be a return value
and we will add that to that element
called I
with the ID container if you look at the
HTML
I think couldn't be much more easy than
that right so you have a span that is
called container what a surprise
and a script that we fetch right main
touch is the one we see over here
nothing too fancy going on so the HTML
will take the JavaScript JavaScript will
fetch the yasm file will instantiate it
call that one function on it and we'll
show this to the browser
so let's he'll hit build again and
there's one important thing that you
have to know if you don't save it you
see it here I have that I have that
circle if you don't save it and you
click build it will not take in your
changes your changes are only in the
compile step if you save it so don't
forget just press ctrl or command s
whatever operating system you are on and
this circle up here will disappear now
when you hit build and run voila this
should be it I hope you all see that can
you try that out if you have build and
run we will send a dress code I think
it's done on the server we'll compile it
make that ransom file load it into the
browser give it 41 the rust will
actually add that plus one and then we
will output it to our browser again does
this not work for anybody or is
everybody happy everybody sees 42 the
answer to all of our questions perfect
nice to see so this is easy right so
let's go into B this a bit more so that
was maybe too easy so yeah ok let's have
a quick look at the instantiation I
already explained that we have to do an
array buffer and webassembly doesn't
Stan she eight expects us to have the
array buffer because it is a binary file
right we can't really do anything else
with it we can't kind of make a choice
on out of
or something so an array buffer is
probably probably the appropriate format
of that whole thing there is a new
method instantiate streaming it's called
so we don't have to deal with the array
buffer this is all done internally so
here we can just add the fetch out of
the fetch promise that we get back into
that instantiate streaming it will be
handled by web sembly or the web
assembly API and we don't have to care
about the array before anymore this is
cool and a little bit more performant
when you have very big binaries that can
make a difference but unfortunately we
have a new ie here so Safari is not yet
on that but I should have it hopefully
soon as of yesterday I think it wasn't
in there but I hope it will be will be
soon oh that's the wrong arrow but now
let's talk about I mean it's all fun
right we we call the function we get an
integer back not very interesting we
want to kind of have this ability to
have a callback right tell rust as soon
as you're done call us back because we
are Chava Script developers there's only
one way to personalities and it's
callbacks cool there is the import
object you see on both of these methods
the instantiate and instantiate
streaming there would be a second
parameter that I didn't tell you about
earlier so next to our array byte array
of bytes we could also input a import
object let's have a look at how that
will look like that import object can
have functions on it and we can actually
pass that into rust at that point and
rust will see these functions and will
actually be able to call them so this is
this is getting cooler right so we get
some functionality done on here so how
is that actually done let's look at the
JavaScript for data first you notice um
just a named it import object a very
simple JavaScript object then there is
one property that we have to set its
this is just expected so all the import
functions interests should be on that nf
property otherwise I think during the
build step the IDE will complain and say
hey your import object doesn't have an
end property so please add that
otherwise you won't be able to actually
call your functions so and if it's just
another object and in here finally our
functions are situated so cool things
and as we know I want to debug right so
I need console log so what I do is I
call it log results as one parameter and
I will just call console log in it so
the cool thing is here right I'm back
other JavaScript functions so my scope
is actually what you would expect if
that JavaScript function so we are not
in some fancy pantsy scoping or
something
when ruffed calls us we are exactly at
that scope you would expect so this is
cool we can use all these window methods
we could use other variables and
functions that will be in our scope like
you would expect it to work
this is fairly cool and in the end you
see webassembly instantiate we have to
ask that import object in there and
we're done on the rough side so the
compiler will obviously complain and say
no no no you call a function that isn't
existing at compile time so we have to
tell the RUS compiler please trust us we
will have that function at runtime you
don't see it anchored at compile time
but that doesn't mean it won't work we
will promise you we will add that
function at one time so this is the
external block with rust we can say that
and say there's a function it will be
called log result and since we can't
pass strings yet we will just pass an
integer so we'll say you can put in one
integer and it's a 32-bit integer we
will obviously look in this a bit more
afterwards so that we can have our
proper hello world project but now in AO
we have to stick to integers
what will it look like then in rust so
if you take the same function as before
you see there is no return type anymore
obviously we call a function right we
don't return an integer anymore
and we have that unsafe block before we
call the function why do we need that
unsafe block rust
tries to be safe like he tries to or he
the compiler tries to make as many
assertions as possible and tries to help
you as much as possible so you won't
screw it up right you won't shoot
yourself in the foot so what it does it
will tell you well this is an external
block I can't help you on that
so you have to wrap your call in an
unsafe block so I actually know this is
expected to be unsafe I can't have all
my assertions on there so as soon as we
have that unsafe block we we won't get
any upsetting messages from our rust
compiler anymore he will just wave it
through and say okay you seem to know
what you do I hope you do let's just go
ahead and compile that
cool so I have to quickly check
something there should be a QR code
somewhere around here I think I skipped
it I'm very sorry that was around here
yes I'm sorry so this presentation is
actually on the web so all the exercises
have these code snippets in there so
please follow my presentation if you
open either bits of Lee's large web
assembly - workshop or scan the QR code
you will get to my index page this is
the page that you saw before from there
you can open these various presentations
so every chapter every chapter is an own
presentation so keep that index open so
we'll always have the possibility to
jump into any chapter you want to did
everybody get the link everybody on the
page perfect so now we are at three
chapter three so if you open that you
will get to this slide over here so
please take a look at these arrows so
usually what I do is I have these kind
of topics and we have an exercise we
will go down vertically so you can
navigate with your arrows or you can
click on these arrows so whenever we are
in an exercise you have to navigate
vertically to find the code examples
that you will be using for that current
exercise so now we are at
here cultures functions from rust if you
hit escape you will get into this
overview so this is actually the last
exercise for that chapter can go into
here and then you see all these code
blocks and in the end you have the link
again for web assembly studio so let's
try to do that let's try to call a
JavaScript function from rust so you
have all the code examples that you use
to create this exercise go to web
assembly studio try to recreate that and
if you have any questions I'll be around
just come and ask me or I will come to
you let's take like 10-15 minutes let's
see how long you need for that and then
discuss the exercise any questions for
that cool happy hacking
are you the outlaws
so far clear I think it's quite easy
right it's not too much to ask
the audio quick I probably can't do
anything about that right
which is so that so is that
I hope so
is it okay if I take a picture of all of
you working or is there anybody who
wouldn't wanna have
yes how could I give a console furnace
oh oh yeah let me let me
just got a very good question so how do
you see the console of that your actual
browser console is to console for that
either IDE so if you open up your
console you will see whatever you do
with console log and stuff like that so
you should see it in here
when I click this building
yeah
it doesn't do anything not cause a long
one yeah I mean that's easy this is
weird for me to try here well yeah you
can but I'm just oh did you safe did you
forget to save oh that's that's so
stupid I I stumbled over that a lot of
times don't worry the way
sorry
coming
yeah that looks simple associated by it
oh oh look at this mind should be bite
see ours there's an S missing let's try
it like that
always safe so stupid that looks better
right yeah perfect you also see it over
here I think yeah it also like if you
look at comes what
okay
yeah
the return oh yeah look what was he tall
seus um he expected to have an i-32 but
he found a function so you just have to
remove the return type right because we
are a void function right if you cha
always yeah that's annoying cause we are
not used anymore to having to click Save
right perfect here you go right sure
like then don't block me though
no the idea is that you actually call
this from your rusts code right so here
you are in JavaScript so you can remove
that over here but go into your rust
file and you should be able to call it
from here so what you can do is remove
that return type from your function
right say this is not returning anything
anymore and then you can call it here
lob result that
exactly and you have to have that unsafe
block around it and see yeah that's it
can you look at the slides I think if
you go down a bit yeah you can see
because because the compiler will expect
you to only call functions that are safe
so cool let's try it yeah
did you say
cool sure
oh there isn't there what happens oh we
still have the return type yeah
either you did that or you remove the
return type right because we don't
necessarily have to return all the thing
but this is okay - yeah I'll write it
out safe this is when you're not on the
file then come on this will trigger to a
chrome come on Esther Oh Oh perfect cool
yeah do you not need to know manga like
extend stuff no because this is actually
from rust I did it expects you to say
these are external functions so I love
not remember it will not open to my stop
block away yeah yeah
was yeah if rough composite to say why
don't we you see directly instant we can
so rest doesn't not compare to see right
rust compares to wasn't binary it we
will use to see types to move between
JavaScript and rust so rust itself uses
its rust compiler and they'll be
compiled to its own binary it will not
be see but we will use the C types to
move between JavaScript because
JavaScript knows C kind of strings we
will get our will explain it when we get
to that because we kind of have to tell
JavaScript we have to read it from
memory ourselves right so we have to
know what format is that string and the
C string is just bytes with a zero at
the end so this is easy to read for us
does it mean I can you see with rust see
see with you mean like enter see real
see any rust
and fifty types
I don't know rust enough for that I
could work but I haven't ever tried it
rust was created solely for the purposes
where was them no rust is actually one
of it should be a easier approachable
language than C but should be pretty
similarly low level and they just when
they came out it was like oh there's
webassembly
we will do a first citizen compiled
target for rust so rust is just kind of
coincidence that is so heavy on our
assembly so I think yes tell me
so add one there is another function
show me your arrest code whose part that
makes good
yeah yeah exactly there's some other
sort of failure than yourselves
yeah this is me
I don't see it right away
import object is to write reference
PGI exactly it's not perfect this is
what you're expected to do yeah yeah I
mean looks good
can actually the rest again and address
some stuff yeah that's what she's really
calling from the last measure oh yeah
oh no I mean a telepaths frame is fairly
you see can I go to the rest again um
all you need to know mangle to be right
above the function so the compiler
removed a functionary that's the issue
yeah Oh is a good question
[Music]
I'm not sure
what is this
split can you open can you kick it
oh it's just another okay
I'm sorry we agree the ball you want to
become thank you I am very very
sorry I don't know
come or maybe just reloaded but yeah I
mean then you will lose your code
obviously I I don't know I'm sorry
cool did it work for everyone anyone
having problems with it we can otherwise
look at it in the break if you want to
because we are already almost there but
let's quickly go through this oh so I've
been higher it's very so let's quickly
go to their web assembly project and
just do what we said so I think a lot of
you noticed you can actually just copy
paste the code from here it will work or
it should work so what we need I'm sorry
this is a bit can never can anybody can
everybody read that right cool so we
have the import object over here just
add it like that there is no return
value in the end for this so a lot of
people noticed it themselves you can
remove that here don't have to but in
the end we want to call log result right
we don't have to return anything anymore
from the add one function yeah so let's
take the rust external block over here
yes
make sure that this no mangle is
directly above your function if you take
this away and like move it up to here
the compiler will not care about it
anymore because it's only meant to be on
top of a function so the compiler
actually knows this function will be
staying in there forever
okay so now we only have to call this
log result with X plus let's multiply up
for once and this is important here when
I don't return anything anymore I need
to remove that type right if I leave
that in the compiler will tell me no no
no so I figure I look at that you see
now rust is always returning the last
expression so what he says is I expect
you to return an integer 32-bit but what
you did is you returned a function call
since log result is a function call so
these messages down here I think the
rest compiler is actually quite a nice
compiler it helps you with rather nice
messages so always take a look at the
output down here usually it helps so
let's remove that and the last thing we
have to do at that unsafe block so this
is all let's quickly try it out if it
really works well build and run it so
yeah I think a lot of you already
struggled with that command s all the
time I'm sorry we are not used to that
anymore right that we have to save
manually ok you see a t2 and also what I
said before actually in your browser
console you see this is no trick we
really put in the console log function
that we think we put in cool so that's
it for the first part that was easy
right oh yeah you can't see the quiz
already
okay if you want to go check that out
web assembly on MDM I mean as always
Mozilla developer Network documentation
just fantastic and webassembly studio is
actually an open source project you can
go i mean maybe you've seen that there's
a github issues but when you write you
can go there you can check it out you
can build it on your own machine and run
it locally very cool so you don't need
internet for it to work I think to learn
and teach like this actually a very cool
project so this will already be our
first short break so you can kind of
maybe go pee and drink something and we
will see you again in 15 minutes so for
10 minutes after 2:00 so that I'm clear
get it working yeah
getting combined exactly yeah exactly
oh okay no I think I brushed over that a
bit this is the actual rust compiler so
what the web assembly what the studio
down here does I will explain that after
a short break there's a build there's a
built type script file I should have
explained that I will do that after the
break
yes can we directly open in the browser
also because like we have some HTML
content over there is it possible this
main dot HTML file I downloaded from
there so if I download this all these
file comes GSRs and maimed or HTML so
okay if everyone's still here doesn't
look that way
well that's okay they will get back soon
I see people coming cool are there any
unanswered questions right now there's
something I didn't really explain all
that well so I will try to explain that
now some people ask me how does this
actually gets compiled right I didn't
really tell you that so over there and
there's ability as that ominous file and
this is how this is actually being built
and let's quickly look into it so we use
code still people using gulp today
Wow a few phew that's cool I haven't
used call for a while so this was a kind
of a reminder for
that I don't know it anymore so we have
one task here built and you see there is
this service if you go look at web
assembly studio github repository you
will find they have a little service
here which will make a call to their
back-end so what's happening here is we
get to file main rust and we send it to
the backend to be compiled we say look
this is a rust file and we want you to
build it for web assembly what we will
get back is that object called data we
will see it later on and then we will
create your project a new file out main
razzin this one and will set data to
what we go back from the back end so the
chava scripts the char script code
doesn't have to compile now right
but the rust code has to compile and we
can't really compile rust in the browser
probably would be possible somehow right
but it's easier now so what they do is
send it to the backend
let it be compiled on the backend and
get the binary back and I create a file
with it so we have to find a actual
binary file we will look into that a
little bit later I was always also
getting the question like rust is
another webassembly only language rust
wasn't invented with kind of web
assembly in mind I think it's more of a
coincidence that when they actually
came out with rust that webassembly was
right there so they said let's make
webassembly one of the default or one of
the easy to access compilation targets
so this is basically everything
it is rust you could also obviously
compile rust just to an executable and
then run it on any machine you want that
they support this is just cool and it
was very easy for me to make these
teaching cases here right so that's why
I was using rust so we don't compile
rust to see or anything anything here we
come
pile rust to webassembly binary just a
clarification about that okay so let's
go to our in-depth exercises that
webassembly in-depth so I mean it's all
fun right we pass some integers but
that's not really mind blowing like why
would we pass integers in these
functions it doesn't really help us a
lot and the use cases well maybe we have
that extremely hard to calculate math
function okay maybe that could be
something that is cool but let's be
honest what we want to do is we want to
pass arbitrary data right we want to we
want to be able to really have an API
where we can pass what every every we
want so how do we handle these kind of
complex types let's start with not the
most complex type right string currently
some of you might have tried that if you
want to pass a string it will fail
miserably you will get fancy exception
messages that this is not working
so Watson currently only knows these
integers and floats types as I mentioned
before integer 32 and 64-bit and float
32 64 bits so what we have to do to
actually be able to pass strings is in
rust we will allocate memory
on our linear memory array write a
string into there take the pointer
return it because the pointer is an
integer is 32-bit right so we can take
that point to return it from our
function to JavaScript so JavaScript now
has an index right
it's like 1347 or something whatever
that just points to an element in the
memory array so we go to the web
assembly part in JavaScript take the
memory out of there well the memory
array and say I want to read the byte at
that position and then I'm gonna
increase and read every byte until I
find a byte that is 0 because we are
gonna deal with the C string
implementation that means we have utf-8
strings every byte is a utf-8 fight and
it will be finished by a zero as soon as
we read a zero we know we're done if we
read over it you will get that classical
in exercise of fans exception and stuff
like that
so let's not do that yeah so how does
that look so now we get into rust a
little bit more bear with me here for a
quick while it's not that complicated so
you see we have some imports we have
another return type and we do some fancy
stuff here with C strings so let's break
it down
part by part so in rust usually stuff is
immutable
so when we have mutable things we will
prepend mu T for mutable for all of you
that now C or C++ that asterisk means we
have a pointer we will not return the
string we will return the pointer to the
memory location where that string is in
and the C char is kind of an alias
bye-bye rust that is the C type so since
C types are native they were I a bit
from architecture to architecture so
rust made like one Aaliyah's for that
char character type in
see that is called C underscore char so
this means nothing else that we are
handling a C type in here so in the
memory there will be that character type
of C then we have this a higher level
construct of rust the C string object so
this is for us that has a lot of these
helpers on it so we can actually
instantiate it do things with it like
you know it from from other high level
languages right we have just this string
helpers so what we can do we take that
in here make new so we have that C
string object now this means the bases
down below is what I just mentioned
before we have a string that is now null
terminated so there will be a 0 in the
end when we write that to the memory
there will be a 0 at the end this is
important for us because otherwise we
would probably fail then as soon as we
have that C string object we have to
make sure that we get to that point in
turn so the first thing is we do the
first thing we do is unwrap it what that
means is it will take like an unboxing
it will take away that C string stuff
and we will be left with that C
character type this is what we want then
with interim we will convert it to a
pointer instead of the actual type we
will have a pointer in our hand this is
what we want also a very relevant
side-effect of that rust will not
garbage-collected right we have to care
about that if we don't use that variable
rust will eventually go ahead and say oh
I don't need that string anymore and
kill it and if we are in Chaves you have
trying to read that yet this this will
not work right this will throw an
exception obviously so interro
will do that for us we will have a
pointer and
we'll not garbage collected anymore but
memory leaks I hear you say
so now rust is not garbage collecting it
anymore it is not on the Chow escaped
not on the Chavez script heap
so that means Java Script is not garbage
collecting it either so what happens is
it will stay in that memory not good not
good
but obviously we can fix that and please
bear with me here this is a hack I know
that but it will do what we want so we
can have another function that is called
deallocate string it will take exactly
that pointer that we just returned right
I pointed to a seed character and what
it will do is it will instantiate a
variable from that string and not use
that variable anymore so rust will
garbage collecting eventually eventually
it's not life you know so we're just
creating a stupid variable that is good
for nothing but with that kind of hack
we give the garbage collection back to
rust we say hey here take that string
and when you don't use it anymore free
the memory that's what we do here this
is just a helper function this is not
what we want to look into it most but
this this will help us not make memory
leaks so you will never have to care
about weird memory issues
yeah you saw up here there's again our
lovely little unsafe block this one here
right we need that because we are
reading an arbitrary pointer you could
pass in any interpreter rust can't
validate that so it doesn't know is that
an actual pointer to our memory or will
it overflow the memory is it type safe
you say this is a C character right but
you just give me a pointer it could be
anything so everybody who had to work
with C++ at some point it probably knows
the issues around dangling pointers and
stuff like that so we have to tell rust
please just trust us we are engineers we
know what we are doing probably cool so
we have to rust park we make a string we
return it as a pointer and we have an
infection that we can call to deallocate
that string again so the rough side it's
already but the JavaScript side is not
yet there so you see there's a little
function here it looks very nice and
fluffy at all that's copy C string
function I mean how hard can it be to
read from memory right oh yeah that's it
so I don't expect you to fully
understand that if you want to go ahead
take a look at it
what it basically does is we have a
generator function up here and this is
looping over the memory with that wire
and you see it will stop when it hits a
zero what I said before right we start
at a certain point err we loop over each
byte in the array and we will when we
will hit the zero we say get we're done
we have the whole string if there is no
zero we will loop and loop and loop
we will eventually crush so let's hope
that doesn't happen so what we do here
you in eight array so unsigned integer
array then we have to decode it right so
now we have an array of bytes so we
basically have a copy of that memory
snippet where the string is and this is
this is relevant to get we now have a
copy so JavaScript has that string in
its own heap now as I copy it's still in
the web assembly part that's why we have
to free the memory but JavaScript copied
the string now what we need to do is the
text decoder utf-8 we know each of these
bytes is a utf-8 character so we have to
tell JavaScript hey read this fight as
utf-8 characters and voila
we should get a string in the end
hopefully and what you see down here
this is where we call it so we take that
original pointer you see that up here we
safe this point to that we get in we
save it initially and then in the end as
soon as we have copied that string we
call that funny little D allocation
method here so rust will garbage
collector string that is not the passing
memory so we don't have to care about
that anymore and in the end we return
that string so this is now a utf-8
decoded string cool
and this is what we will do now yeah so
yeah we are in chapter 4 handling
complex sites you can go down here all
the code you need is basically in here
go ahead try it out and in the end if
everything works we are very close to
having a proper hello world function
yeah I think we we take 15 minutes for
that I would say because this is a
little bit harder
when I get into this yeah oh yeah
could I try something
and now to be honest let's
that's amid last thing here and removed
Elsa statement like just follow through
right
this is right Lucas okay so let me Creek
you train without the semicolons I had
some issues when it would add
semi-colons so
you never know just to be sure
three two one and then 0 and then
it's just what he expects to see
what do we expect to see Fibonacci
should always and up the last two
numbers right yeah
so this case I objected reasons I
supposed to be returning just three
plus one
yeah this is what it does right
two-one-zero one that's kind of weird
here but the first can we kind of take
that out for a second just to see what
the actual results oh can you comment
that sorry but I'm so bad before
yes exactly that's cool exactly Oh X has
to be X
perfect
so we drink them something doing wrong
because firstly smaller equals one or a
pen Thanks
so it should never be melted write a
zero right because yeah
kind of make sure of that Wow
now it can be right if X is 2x minus 2 0
so I think the algorithm is wrong
let me quickly check
and they increased up to it too I'm not
sure if that's right I'm not very good
at math I have to have it
so what happens now when we take of life
so far two plus three is that right
I'm sure I think yeah I think what the
basic problem was I think you should
probably omit semicolons and return
statements as much as you can because I
had some real issues with semicolon but
I'm too bad a trust to tell you what the
actual problem it is so I think what you
do works now you probably have to just
figure out what the correct mathematical
algorithm is else for probably I think
else is I think else is okay and I just
took that out to be sure can you write
yeah
yeah yeah I think the semicolon from the
other piece I'm sure Feli methods like
this right yes
so like earlier also in the same yeah
yeah cool cool yeah Jessica
ODU's has actually have to be on the top
oh yeah sorry
I should have mentioned that I guess
cool let's try it out
so you have to copy strain method yeah
exactly a copy to dry it over write this
note or two on top or here fine it's
fine blue anodized now you have to be in
here right because here you don't have
access to the the actual web assembly
instance so it has to be in here exactly
yeah cool so we are in the right scope
now yeah so run it
kind of here you go thanks strength tell
me
print the message should we the other in
this frame already or the allocation
happens in the copy string method you
see it here because the thing is we
copied right so JavaScript will care it
for its own string that we will actually
print out it will care about right we
have garbage collection we just have to
make sure that after reading it that
webassembly memory is freed so this
string up here this will be garbage
collected by JavaScript that's all okay
perfect I don't have anything in the
local school can you check in the global
scope is there any global scope variable
things like that in Russ to me outside
so it was not able to identify so there
is no concept of global variable system
so you are here in Charles crypt right
so your global variables window in here
so we are in basic JavaScript you have
the window object available to you
anytime in inches but Russ doesn't have
something like that
Russ doesn't no way window that's why it
extract everything to be in the method
no no this is just us you had you get
the actual web assembly instance in here
in that method so here you access
results instance experts right you can't
access that above that right because
this is a promise you are in the promise
then a block so you have your
asynchronous right so you don't have you
don't have any access to that instance
from the outside
that's why we have to be in there okay
yes
opposed to get it like ya understand
and not necessarily why yeah tell me
quite sure why on store whether and
stuff
registering for you yeah because the rep
assembly interface defines four times so
Ross knows types strings those types
strings sorry JavaScript no sites but in
between the interface where they have to
go through only knows integer and float
that's our base problem yeah this is one
of those things I showed with an e ref
and the host bindings they should
leverage that but currently this is the
limit yeah right yeah so yeah we are
pointer magic yes I was just trying to
change the code a little bit
oh yeah cool nice extra scripts
excellent
yeah it's deallocate string thing that
we're beginning from
don't love the idea of passing
around the whole module like it just got
weeds that's cool yeah the thing was you
need to make sure if you need to have
the memory yeah exactly
because we need we need the memory
buffer right that's a rate that we're
gonna read from so we have to make sure
that this is in there what we're getting
back from here is not just the exported
functions this isn't like exporting
exactly memory memory is something that
webassembly exports for you so you can
actually access the memory array of what
they're certainly absolutely you get
that for free kind of so there's a whole
bunch of like exports is it's not a lot
I think its memory and your function I
think it's really here is just go memory
yeah yeah exactly so yeah can actually
pass it in yet
uh-huh
now in also naming those with like I
guess there's our us conventions to use
underscore I really like mixing these
when I get a job it's the same thing oh
yeah
you have to kind of make sure here now
we have a name clash to make sure
and that's that one is it yeah that
one's absolutely yeah that's another
so China
and I suppose you get to find this a
utility function the elegance ring is
another function well do you have a typo
in there or something could it be
you know oh you don't have it in here
you need to deallocate from yeah no no
it's really only actually memory that is
and they've I think it's pretty much on
the top but you go yeah yeah exactly
that one anything and then Oh mango
don't forget to know my heart knowing do
I need it you need it for each function
absolutely
that's why that wasn't working I thought
that was just a oh yeah though you need
it on each function absolutely that's
just a rough thing so yeah
now I can be happy yeah yeah now you can
do the naming that you want to go here
yeah sometimes it's a bit quirky you
have to be in here click in here then
yeah that's good Cup
cross fingers I see this to not defile
this
did I
well oh yeah take an actual call so
that's cool it could read until there
right so it seems like now yeah here you
go
cool
yeah
yes so you mentioned that you asked them
the execution of the Wesen is actually
running on but we yeah yeah so how does
the browser give is synchronous or is it
not service
I mean my JavaScript calls the lesson
then do something else in JavaScript
again yeah this is not synchronous
so you have two separate runtimes yeah
well but rough the sinker so when you
call add 1 this will be directly
executed so your JavaScript code won't
run any further
so you know it's not like you have
promises around your webassembly calls
it's just like it's two to run times but
when you say call dad one function it
will directly return synchronous so this
is synchronous because the Java is
waiting for the rest it the exact is
like the call style so dress colors on
the call stack and the next thing
JavaScript can do is actually access
okay
okay I hope that most of you have gotten
this to work this is kind of a cool
little thing when you realize okay now I
read something from memory in JavaScript
I've never done that before like this is
let's say the most low-level thing I've
done in JavaScript so let's try it out
so I'm gonna try that quickly too
let's remove what I have here and just
add that in write the second function in
we saw here the allocation this one so
some of the people in here asked me you
need that no manual in front of every
function otherwise the compiler removes
your functions so if you forget one of
these no manuals that's when you
probably get some issues like this is
another function and stuff like that so
you need it in front of every function
so this is all the roughs code we have
right we have two methods welcome
message and the allocate string and I
will remove that import object for now
so it's a bit easier overview for you
guys and paste that in so make sure that
this JavaScript star is in the them in
here right you need access to that
instance that you just created since
this is asynchronous we can't paste that
code up here right because results is
not accessible from up here because this
will be only available after we loaded
everything so we have to have that code
in here let's remove these two lines oh
cool
this so we instantiate we get the module
results instance experts and then we
call get welcome message then we copy
that see string oh the C string function
so let's copy that as a whole so we
don't have to worry about whoop and when
we build and run this it should say
hello from rust oh oh hello from rust
cool so what we did is we passed
pointers yeah
pointed out that arithmetic we read from
that memory so you might have seen this
year we just access module dot memory
web assembly is actually exporting this
memory object for us so this is how we
can access that buffer so the actual
array where we can work on right we need
that so this is the memory from rust in
web assembly that we access here right
away
and yeah as soon as you see hello from
Russells down here you have actually
saved AC string into a memory and read
it from JavaScript and passed it as
utf-8 but this is a bit hard right I
mean we don't have with the string it's
easy well easy
we can't just read until zeroes but try
to pass now arbitrary objects with
arrays in it that's where it's gonna get
really heavy so we don't want to do that
and we don't need to do that so there's
a good tuning for us I only wanted to
show you this so you would actually know
what happens underneath it that you
understand this has to be done because
we only can pass integers and floats but
we're not gonna do that anymore now now
we're gonna have one abstraction between
us and web assembly so it's gonna be
easier for us to stay sane in our head
so every every current language that we
can compile to webassembly
has its own kind of helping tool for
that in rust is called as invention for
c and c++ you might have heard of that
it's called Emscripten people that know
as inches know and Skipton is around for
quite some time now but yeah
it allows us to have high-level
interaction so various types and it does
all this post bindings kind of for us so
we can now pass in and out of of
webassembly whatever we feel like and we
will see that this can really be alone
what's also cool is imagine banchon can
actually generate typing for you for
typescript so that's in my opinion a
huge boss here that the bat tool does
very well we will not look into that
because of time constraints we won't
have time to explore all the options but
you could theoretically generate
typing's from your rust code so in
typescript you would actually know what
this function is returning and what it
can pass into it at any time which would
be nice the downside of this now we have
a wrapper between web assembly and rust
or the web assembly interface and rust
and JavaScript and the web assembly
interface because when we send some
arbitrary object on the JavaScript side
we kind of have to transform that and
save it into an array and from the rough
side the same right we have to know how
is this kind of stored but we don't want
to see it so we generate code now on the
JavaScript side and on the on the Watson
side
rust site and we will only interact with
resin now through that resin bind chain
how that looks
we will see it right away so what now
happens is when we compile a ransom file
it will actually compile into a
JavaScript file and a vassal file on the
JavaScript side we have the bindings so
that we actually know
how we read these arbitrary types and on
the western side we have to compile
dress code plus also these bindings so
JavaScript and rust know what the other
part is gonna save into memory and read
from memory so we have to kind of
abstract that for us so we have
basically we have three steps to do we
have to make sure that the bust is
compiled with Rasim banchon so this is
actually a compiler extension in that
sort then we we need to make sure that
the compiler knows it was invention it
will compile it with was invention and
we will need to make sure that these
chase findings that I talked about are
loaded into the browser before we access
web assembly because they have to be
there to have to provide us all these
wrappers to to send all these arbitrary
types in and receive them out of we're
assembling how does that look like on
the website it's it's kind of easy there
is this line up here that helps us with
that oh I'm sorry this one I will not go
into that too much this is Russ and we
save us that we need some macros to be
executed for that I think that's a
detail we just omit for that workshop so
we don't have to go into rust macros and
all that stuff we're just gonna leave
that out for a moment this will activate
Wes invention for the compiler so we can
actually use all of it then we say it
there's an external crate the crate
that's like an NPM package for rust so
there's a massive engine crate this will
actually loads the library that we will
then be using and here we say that we
need this preload that will help us with
all the helper functions that we will be
using now the actual rust code doesn't
look all that's different you see up
here this is slightly different instead
of no manual vasin banshan introduced a
new introduces a new flag it's called
Bassem binds chain
the compiler for one no mango please
don't remove it but on the other hand it
will also make sure that all these types
are working correctly then you see we
can just return a regular rough string
as you would expect it that's cool
so this is what we do here but what we
get in is a string reference I will get
into why this is the case this is a
little macro from Russ that is just
helping us we can have these braces here
and all the parameters you will add
afterwards will be replaced into these
spots with the braces so this is just a
fancy print line right nothing else this
will return a string that is hello comma
and then whatever you pass into it as a
name so the rest function isn't that all
that complicated this is all that we
have to do on the rough side so far so
cool yeah these macros by the way you
always see them because of the
exclamation mark rust has this best yeah
rust does this that every mark row has
to have this exclamation mark in its
name
but I said we're not going to look into
more of these markers we just use it for
creating that string that's all it has
to do so this is the case here that's
relevant javascript strings are utf-16
and they have some limitations to that
so how pairs are matched up I am way too
stupid to explain this so rust the rust
guys they have done a cool documentation
why it's hard to go from this utf-16 to
that utf-8 of rust without getting these
nice little black boxes with question
marks in it so this is why they give you
that reference they have to do some
stuff that it is guaranteed that that
string will never have on
glanceable characters in it so this is
why you get a string a reference of a
string in the end there's a base type
behind that it's called chase string
that's what they used to actually
convert all that stuff if you want to
read up on that these are good good
starting points but this would kind of
be too much for that workshop now so
we're just gonna accept the fact that
when we have something in JavaScript
that we have to when we get a string or
give it back we'll have this reference
reference type here so there's one last
thing if you recall the diagram from up
above this one when I showed you that
builds of TS file
you saw that the ransom file is only
compiled the rust file is only compiled
into one thousand file and we have to
change that now right because we have
these JavaScript bindings so what
webassembly studio is providing us this
is what it is now right service dot
compiled trial but webassembly studio
actually has compiled a file with
bindings very cool so what that does is
back here we have the same call we say
we enter main rust it is rust code you
have to generate Watson code and the
same options but the return type is
slightly different because if you look
at it before we have this data object
and we would just say Avastin sets the
other but what we do now is that data
object has actually two properties on it
now one is Bazin this is the binary and
is Bassem bindings chase bank Chen sorry
so we create two files here so this is
the basic difference we have one out
main dot Bassem file and we have one
main underscore bindings that jeaious so
now we created both so we compiled a
trust into JavaScript and interest a
business sorry
the only thing that we need to make sure
now is that is actually loaded into HTML
before or other script is actually
execute it so this is I mean it's kind
of trivial right so we just load that
main by next is that we just created in
the build step and that's all we need to
do so how does the JavaScript side look
like so this is different now
you remember that before we have to call
fetch and array buffer and then whoever
same did not instantiate with their
buffer all of this is now done by Wesen
binds chain as I told you we do not
interact any more directly with
webassembly
we will interact only through Bassem
binds chain this is our interaction
point now to actually get this code
running so the string is the same right
we just say hey take that file and
instantiate and what we get when that
promise returns the instance is ready
wherever somebody started up and we can
just call it you see that this function
is then calling that greet method and
this is the second thing that is new up
here except instead of having to go
through instances of experts and then
calling dot greet on it
vasin binds chain is providing us the
experts as these these properties on
that global object so vasin binds chain
is on our window object this is a global
object that we now have and we can get
all the exports from there so if you
want to make it easier
not have these destructuring things you
could also go ahead and just say vasin
underscore bind chin doctor greet right
this is the same so here we just have
that fancy restructuring so we take
creed out of it as a standalone function
but you could also oh well not like this
but like this you could just call it
like that this is just as every window
object properly as you know you have
access to it its global you can't just
go ahead grab whatever you want to and
execute it yeah so maybe if you go to
the exercise delete your existing
JavaScript and rust coat and take the
ones from these examples so you don't
have any clashes with names or something
so you don't end up trying to track down
some naming issue or anything so this is
all the code you need for that yeah
exactly that's what I already said that
that main bindings is this is actually
the code there's the script that does at
this vasin binds chain property to the
window object and we will have access to
that now yeah so there's three things we
have to do we try to pass these strings
now without having to read on the memory
which would be cool right so make sure
that it's comparative present Bancha and
import these bindings and then you
should be all set for that so let's try
that out I would say we take another 10
to 15 minutes depending on how many
questions there are
is it any fun well that doesn't sound
fun
for what this time that's a reference of
a string reference but that's that
specific jeaious style reference that I
mentioned because of that utf-16
position this is what it does yeah it's
good it's a little bit weird and then
are these like no like this is like them
yeah this is kind of rust macros for the
compiler yeah yeah exactly and then
instead of having like yeah rust has is
called rust hacker yes
yeah the third hole dependency
resolution stuff
yeah
sorry oh yeah I'm sorry
exactly if you I will ever show it if
you look at these bindings you will see
that it does pretty much what we did
earlier so you see that this all
generator code now
but you see here they do the cache get
you into it from memory they go to that
buffer they take that array they have
the text encoder you see they pretty
much do it the same way as we did before
nice that's it with another
but Serena's NPM package crate ishes
extends package the shelf a pastor says
not even maven dependencies doesn't
every Ruthie okay
rust I am NOT a heavy user of wrath no
but I think we have rust developers but
nah I wouldn't know of any her abduction
project we have a rest I think there are
smaller services when each company as a
kind of thing which is that I use so I
think we have customers that have small
services written in rust and go for a
gold you
yeah rust is very easy to teach the
basics PO there will be one more
exercise and then we'll be done with the
basics that we get on to the fun stuff
so let's let's discuss that
okay so let's discuss this exercise
quickly this will be the second-to-last
basic exercise so bear with me for one
more and then we will have the fun
exercise where we will actually do a
more real world real world example right
because this helps us understand it but
it doesn't really reflect what we will
use it for afterwards so let's quickly
go through it we import the crates that
we need we ask that one function here to
actually get that hello world message
yeah
then we extend our build step like this
so this isn't that bill TS that I
mentioned before right so we take this
one out and X oops like this replace it
with the new one
so in here now you see that we do the
main wasm and that main bindings chance
cool so we got to rust all set up we get
the build step to do what we want so we
need to import the script in our main
HTML that's around here this one cool
and then there is just the JavaScript
left so let's take that in as well
nice so if we build and run that now we
should see hello JS conveys Asia perfect
that's what we wanted to see nice okay
so you see now here we have the main
mass of the binary and start bindings if
you take a look at that bindings fine so
this is all generated so it's a bit ugly
code but if you check what they do you
see that they also use the text encoder
that we used before they go to the
memory buffer as we did before they do
this unsigned integer array a decode
stuff and then you see function pass
string 2000 which allocates memory on
the rough side and then writes the
string in the buffer and everything like
that so they pretty much do what we did
before so that's what wasum invention is
now
- right so we don't have to care about
that anymore it's not nice College since
its generated but now we don't have to
care for ourselves anymore right we
don't have to maintain that memory stuff
and read everything out of there Rasim
binds Chen we'll take care of this so
that's actually what we wanted very cool
so there's just one thing left and then
we have all the basics covered or yeah
all all major basics covered before we
are able to call JavaScript functions
out of rust can we also pass rings back
to JavaScript right we didn't or not
pass Rings back but call a javascript
native function with a string you
haven't proven that yet so this is a
very small exercise it uses Basma
banchon again so you know that little X
term blocks that we used earlier for our
log results function we can leverage
that a bit and add that lesson bind
chain up there what that will do is well
combined chain on the JavaScript side
will search for the function and try to
inject that on the instantiation phase
of your web assembly so when we don't
say anything
Masum banshan will go to the global
scope window and will search that
function so this will inject window dot
alert so now we have the window alert
function passed into it we don't need to
do anything on the JavaScript side since
this will all be done in our binding
strayer's that will be generated by our
compile step so the charge cube it's not
not different this is a thing that we
only have to do on the rough side and
pass invention will inject the correct
functions now you think like you have
what if I want to
some specific functions so they have it
covered if you say nothing there's no
flag it will search for window dr.
Holland if you say hey hey the chance
namespace is console Wes invention will
go for window that console that lock so
this is how we would inject comes along
and if we want to have it twice you know
the console log statement of JavaScript
obviously takes in our arbitrary types
rusts doesn't really know that right
Russ doesn't know that pass me anything
log statement pass me an array or an
object log statement so if you want to
have a second console log injected with
just another typing you see here we say
unsigned int 32 bit and here we say
string reference you can even go further
and say okay the Chinese name spaces
console and the function name is log but
in Russ that function name will be
console underscore log on the scoring
you 32 so a bass invention will not look
at your function name anymore
it will only check these two variables
if you set them and just from there
we'll search the correct function to
pass into our web assembly code so
lesson function will set up that import
object it will add the correct functions
into that import object and will pass
them in so we don't have to care on the
JavaScript side anymore because that
JavaScript bindings file will do it all
for us is that is that kind of clear
yeah
console
okay so the question was if you want to
come to look master look
you mean the JavaScript math that love
so what you would do is another line
here and you would say the JavaScript
namespace is math right so let's just
write it if it would go like that oh
this is written like this so this one
now vasin ban channel will now go to
window dot math dot log so that would
now be the logarithmic function right
master logarithm so now I could go ahead
and say console log underscore u-32 and
call this log function well this is a
bit the naming is not very nice right
because it looks like it's a log
statement but this is math dot love
everything so we would probably go ahead
and say okay that jeaious underscore let
me quickly get that into you so I can
actually write that chase name is log
master lock and here we would probably
say like math underscore log and integer
would be a 32-bit integer probably so
this is how we wouldn't check the math
function right so math dot log would now
be available for us at math underscore
log in rust and then we can go ahead and
say okay and we need a third function
well
oops okay good and that is the console
log function again and this time we want
to add a 32-bit integer into it so we
would say this is now console underscore
log on this car I thirty two like this
so now we have both methods in there
right so we now inject it the math
logarithm function and we inject the
console log but other completely
different names so they are not kind of
messing up our brains the stomach
okay so let's try to do that this is a
short exercise just trying to do
whatever function you would like pass it
in see if you can call it if you can
alert hellos like this example that I
think other year you could do a alert
hello world or something and have fun
with it
yeah let's take five to ten minutes try
that out and that will be the last basic
exercise after that we will do some fun
image processing that we actually see
what webassembly is capable of we just
had to learn the basics first so we
understand what happens under the hood
be there in a second yeah
I was curious
it's gonna like waiting until that's
ready before coals the function and uses
okay Adam yeah yeah from here what is it
yeah this is only setting up the web
assembly instance right because Bassem
binds chen already knows what you are
exporting your us because it was there
at compile time right so it already
knows you are exporting a great function
die that's why it provides you that
output what what this is doing is it
loads to binary and then it does
webassembly does instantiate it does
have to set up the web assembly instance
right exactly exactly this is all it
does now does it return anything I think
I don't think Shelton's no I think this
is all handled in that global object
okay I don't think it has a return type
anymore but I'm not on the pension just
I'm sure make sense yeah okay
yeah
like something in navigator which good
question so when you when you look at
the choice that it's actually putting
out did you did you build that now not
yet try to build that quickly because
you see what it actually does and then
it can kind of see what you would expect
it to to input there so now a search for
one of the methods you import it like
what did you do console log or something
what do we have the alert search for the
other function because you should see it
here now
oh yeah so you see what it does it's
fairly weird
so you see actually it creates a new
function for you and in there it will
call the alert so it's kind of wraps
your function so if that would be
undefined you would get undefined this
is another function right yeah that
would be what happens okay so under that
specific case yes they were throwing her
in Chaves good
exactly exactly yeah well no it was
probably run divestment because this
will be called from from rust right
you'll recover from rust but then on the
JavaScript side it will fail because it
tries to call undefined yeah exactly
exactly
got nice face cut
okay let's already get into the honey
because this is just a last quick
exercise let's just do the basic example
right I think most of you already have
it running if not don't worry so if we
have that external block right this is
all we do we just have to call it from
somewhere so I mean we can make a new
function right so we can say well let's
be honest with our function names right
let's call it alert let's call it alert
hello world this gets in a string and
we'll return absolutely nothing so what
we will do is we will call alert like
this right so we can call that alert
hello world and this should actually
call our alert functions that we should
get a stupid alert message right so
let's just try that so instead of
greeting here we just called a new alert
hello world like this and since we don't
have a return type this line down here
doesn't make any sense so now we call it
like that and this should now throw an
error because I did leave something out
that is relevant so let's just join it
build and run it and see what the rust
disaster that oh so it said I am
expecting you to add this reference
string but you give me a correct
complete string so what I have to do the
issue is now here I have the format
macro which is returning a string well
as you see alert is expecting this so
what I do is I add data saying put the
reference of that
and rust will be totally happy with that
so let's see yeah you see up here well
it's not the best contrast so the native
alert of mine brow is the fire so if we
go here like confirm you know you know
the confirm right with the buttons on it
so let's just call the confirm now what
happens you see I get these buttons up
here so these are really the native
methods right we can't call them now
cool so this was all for the basics I
hope it was okay for you it was fun for
the basics but now we want to see what
an actual real-world use case looks like
so how do we do for example image
processing but I would advise that we
make a short break of ten minutes and
start with the last exercise at
half-past three
soon but we will already start otherwise
we'll get into a hurry for last exercise
and we don't want that so go over to the
the lowest the last one chapter 5
real-world use case this is what we will
look at now so what do I think of
real-world use case um what we will use
this OpenCV does anybody in here know
over the CV a bit are you are you
actively using open CV nobody really
cool so we won't do hard core functions
of open CV so I will explain every
function that we need for those who know
the open CV it's one of the biggest
libraries for computer vision it is
written and C C++ so as you may think
this CV in open CV is computer vision
and the cool thing is in C and C++ right
and if you remember correct if you
remember from my first couple of slides
C and C++ are pretty much done over for
assembly so you can compile them to
webassembly very easily so let's do that
then luckily there is somebody at open
CV who already did this so the standard
built of open CV can be triggered to
compile to basel instead of native
architecture code we won't compile it
ourselves because you will have to
install si Lang compiler and Emscripten
and you would compile it for five to ten
minutes since that is kind of a not so
nice thing to do I did the pre compiling
for us so we already have a
pilot OpenCV library and it's a two
megabytes big so it's not optimal to
send it to the browser often so we'll
try to catch it
oh yeah I forgot to mention a
description so we used vassal bind chain
for rust right so that helped us with
those bindings from rust to JavaScript
all C and C++ side we have MS triptan
and you can basically if if you put it
very simple that's not entirely correct
but if you put it simple it's comparable
to wasn't binds change it does also do
JavaScript bindings it will help us to
have this high level interaction with
all the types we want to so this is
gonna help us a lot and this is what
OpenCV internally uses when you compile
it to webassembly so let's do image
processing shall we
the first thing you have to do is check
out that literally gives you posit Orion
shouldn't be too big this is the setup
for our last two as a - yeah - exercises
that we will do when you have it when
you downloaded it execute npm install
and npm start and then you should have a
local running web server on port 8080 or
if your part ID ID is actually taken it
will start on 1881 8080 to whatever is
free it will show you in the console you
will not have to restart that web server
because it's just a plain static web
server we have no build come we have no
build step we have no post piece
processing nothing like that so this is
really a stupid web server so you don't
have to restarted or anything just keep
it up and running and the only thing you
have to do is refresh your browser when
you actually change things
okay try to check that out
I hope everybody has an editor River so
like your favorite editor on you we it's
not like you need a super-duper editor
so you will be okay with pretty much any
editor
did everybody manage to clone to get
your posit ory everybody has it perfect
cool as soon as you have it run NPM
install an NPM start and then you should
be able to visit localhost 8080 or
whatever it says on the console if you
don't get a page shown I seen that on
some Windows machines that can happen
then just add a slash index dot HTML to
the URL sometimes HTTP server doesn't
automatically redirect you to the
index.html page I haven't really found
how to properly solve this so if this
happens just add slash index dot HTML in
the end and you should be good if
everything works all right you can open
the console and after some seconds you
should see that console message over
there runtime ready what that means is
whether somebody started with open CD in
it and open CV runtime is ready for you
we don't do anything yet with it so
don't worry if you don't see anything
cool so do you see that les who sees
that message ok like half of you right
ok does anybody have like an error
message or just not there yet
error messages I'll come and see quickly
unless each part closed no post one or
do you have some sort of plug-in up
there that looks like a plugin issue
because you see it's not from the main
chest open it in an incognito window for
once and see if you get that message
there - no okay so it's one of your
plugins don't worry about that who had
an issue
- nobody oh cool
so who sees the console log message now
if some of you okay not too many let's
let's wait for another minute
anybody have exceptions or something are
you stuck
corrupted this looks good
can you try to add / index.html okay
that's that's that issue that I was
mentioning so I don't know why so if you
go to the console now you should see
that runtime ready know that browser
comes out sorry perfect yeah it's the
browser console where that console
statement should be at at the terminal
console okay I hope it works freedom
otherwise when we are at the exercise I
will come to the people that still have
issues good so what do we do from here
right that's not very interesting a very
short introduction to the protec
structure we have three main files to
the relevant in the binary folder you
have the OpenCV Deshaies file this is
the compiled
OpenCV file maybe don't open it there's
a six megabyte
base64 encoded string with the complete
Bassem binary in it it might kill your
editor depending on what you use you can
open it you will see a lot of funny
letters but yeah maybe done and then we
have the index.html and main show us so
a nice little web project no build snap
nothing so I kind of like it already
cool yeah I think I told you that
so the difference to what we did before
this one is not having a battle of the
score bind chain of the window object
what we will get is a CD object so
whenever you want to interact with
OpenCV we will go over that CV dot
whatever it is then whatever function we
cool so let's do our first exercise
first when we wanna have real-time image
processing we need some sort of video
stream right so let's go into WebRTC who
knows WebRTC okay not too many so I'm
gonna quickly show quickly go into it
whatever actually see we can basically
get streams of audio video or both in
the browser the idea the basic idea
where it came from is that he can have
video chats or audio chats in your
browser because that stream that you
have you can send it over the network
and then it can basically make your own
Skype if you want to and that is pretty
much integrated in every browser
nowadays probably except for ie 11 I
wouldn't know this is just a random
guess we won't use that for sending it
over the net we will just fetch the
webcam camera off stream so we have a
stream that we can sample all right that
we can do image processing this is
actually not all that hard
what you do is navigate it of media
devices this is where it's located up
and then it can say get user media and
you have an options object where you can
say what do you want if you look at the
documentation these don't have to be
bullying you actually can add a config
object so you can say I want the
front-facing camera I want the back
facing camera
I want it in landscape mode I want
whatever we are just gonna be very
simple here we say you have one webcam
stream probably on your notebook
I guess just give us that that's all we
need it's a promise we can say then and
in here we will get this dream that's
all we want
cool but what do we do with that stream
now we can get the video tracks since we
are a very simple webcam there will be
one video track so we're just gonna say
give us that first video track can not
care about it anymore we will use that
video track later on you see it down
here we were
the width and the height of our video
stream on there we don't use it from the
start so don't worry about it
these are the settings that we get from
there when you look at the JavaScript
object you see that on the top two lines
I have two elements that I get from the
HTML you can look at them it's a video
element and the canvas element the first
element we are going to use is the video
element so what we can do now the video
element has a property named source
object you can just set this dream on to
the source subject and what will happen
is you will see yourself yeah
so let's try to do that get the video
stream added to the input object a input
video element and see if you can see
yourself or if something goes wrong does
anybody still have problems with running
the project like basically running it
cool
let's just take five minutes or ten
minutes for that depending on how long
it takes you but it shouldn't shouldn't
be too hard
yeah you have to check out the little
gate drop out there it's in their fifth
chapter of the maybe go back to the
index I think it's at just be exactly
there that's the fifth one mm-hmm
but then I think pretty in the first and
the second one one more and that you can
go what to the right and then down this
is to get a rapper that you have to
check out under this one
yes there you are
OSE faces all over the place that's cool
very good
anyway yeah
yeah another face down here
I like cameras
it's working for you get easily they
have unrefined
don't forget either
what
during her
can you make a hard refresh
huh
um how can her
you should media device about that
what
and
did you oh can you check your our ticket
settings if room doesn't have access to
your webcam system security probably I
guess or ein Gavin oh you have it in
English right
that's like accessibility
oh no this is just if it can use the
audio stuff
can you try that in safari quickly Oh -
the camera
you have to click on the lock of the
bonus
huh this is a real
the crow should ask you for that I think
get it try it with Safari that's your
work
yeah
my last example uh-huh
it's arranged and have your family
probably because of our memory do you
have like some sort of loop that is
we can look at that later on I have to
move on Oh
cool
perfect I see a lot of faces on the
screens that seems to be working all
right
does everybody have some major problems
with it or does it work for everybody
working cool okay so that's not really
what we want to do right that's just
what we needed to do to get an input
stream so now we want to have open sea
view right now we have that input stream
and now we want to make sure that we
call our sea library that we just
cross-compiled
or we would compile down to Azen now we
want to really call it and see what
happens so how do we do that
luckily OpenCV has a thing called video
capture that can capture frames from a
video element very convenient so we can
say where we have our video and then we
can say video capture dot read and it
will read a OpenCV matrix out of that
image and then we can work in that
matrix which is cool so this is how it
looks you need to have a global variable
cap and then you can instantiate it with
our input video element we can just say
CV dot video capture and we can
instantiate that with new and this is
how we create our first open CV object
right so open CV is now instantiating
that video capture thing for us so this
is already a very complex type right so
we can already share that between
webassembly and JavaScript which is kind
of fast in
already so this is how we set it up now
OpenCV know is there's a video stream
going on and we just have to pass that
into OpenCV now that we can actually
pinch what we need is the output canvas
needs to have a width in the height we
want to paint that picture that we get
from OpenCV onto a canvas now so
whatever we do on OpenCV we do some
transformations and whatever in the end
we can't put that back into the video
element we have to render that image
that we just did onto a canvas so I made
that HTML element already available to
you it's collage put canvas and you have
to make sure that the size of the canvas
matches the size of our stream otherwise
OpenCV will complain and say well you
try to paint a matrix onto a canvas and
they are not the same size this doesn't
work so it's important that we set width
and height of our canvas
then we need two matrices one is the
source matrix this is what we get out of
the video stream and the other is the
destination matrix in between we will do
some conversion on that mail image right
so we read a matrix transform it into a
destination matrix paint that
destination matrix onto our canvas this
is the steps you are gonna do this is
just how you instantiate them also make
sure that we do that in that start
streaming function we don't want to
create a new matrix with every frame
right this is not fun because that would
be heavy on the memory we can always
reuse the last matrix right we don't
have to do a new matrix all the time
yeah also here it's important that
height and width are really correct and
behind well in the end of that line you
can see these two values of OpenCV what
I mean is you have heard that already
8-bit unsigned int is 8u and c4 means
how many channels we have when we read
from our webcam we get four channels
basically it's RGB and a alpha Channel
so this is what we get in and now for
our first exercise we're going to do a
grayscale so we reduce from four
channels to one channel that is only
gray we will remove all the colors that
is our first easy exercise that we're
going to try
yeah
so we have four things that we have to
do we saw it earlier we set up the video
capture and two matrixes that is already
cool now we have to have some sort of
painting loop right so we have to read
from the video capture then we convert
to grayscale and then we draw to the
canvas and then we call us again and
then we have our basic animation loop
that will fetch from the video stream
grayscale all the things to draw onto
the canvas so how does that look like
the video capture is actually super easy
is a dot read and hand in the source
matrix so what it will do it will
transform that image to a matrix so now
our source matrix has an image in it
cool then we convert the color so OpenCV
has a method called convert : so we say
we go from the source matrix we will
write into the destination matrix and
this is the color transformation that
you have to apply we go from RGB a to
grayscale and last but not least we make
an E and show it's called I am sure we
have to input the canvas element here so
OpenCV knows about that canvas element
and we say which matrix should be
printed onto our drawn onto that canvas
and since the destination matrix is now
our grayscale matrix this is what we
want to do
and Indians loop it
who knows requestanimationframe in here
cool cool ok so for the ones that don't
know it we can ask the browser to call
us in 60 frames per second if possible
this is that function we can hand in the
function and the browser will schedule
us and we'll try to call us every what
is it 13 milliseconds so we have 60
frames per second if that doesn't work
if we are too slow he will just schedule
us as fast as he can without blocking
his rendering loop so this is just a way
that the browser makes sure we are not
spamming user interaction between
browser and JavaScript so in the end of
our function we can say okay we are done
now please reschedule us we want to draw
again and then the browser will will let
us draw again yeah this is it so you
have all the codes you need for the
exercise put it together and see if you
get a greyscale image of yourself on the
right side let's say 10 minutes for now
exactly it has to be yet
mm-hm we can set that up here you don't
have to do it in the in the loop but you
can do it in the loop but you don't have
to that's work you need to do once right
and that it's good yeah
oh yeah I would do let's see the
initialization of these things you can
also do up here right you don't you only
have to have to do that once Jesus
messaging I don't believe these martyrs
capture well I just tell you stuck
actually yeah yeah this is we do
initialize all the opencv objects that
we use yeah and this is the function we
want to repeatedly call now right so
these actually do actual reading exactly
this is what we do when for each frame
right that we can so this part should be
in here
you should call it from here once but
that function should stand somewhere on
its own like outside of your context for
example that's why we save these things
into the global scope okay so funny
inside yeah it will work it will work so
we can leave it in there if you want to
the only relevant thing is that inside
the function you have to call that
window requestanimationframe again right
because like this you will only be
called once and you have to tell the
browser yeah okay that should work
kinds of input monster-sized should be
the same as to video so let me see
Oh Oh you have to do that after you set
the stream because before that it will
not oh no no no I should work
you should work you're right sorry I'm
getting the value from
the video track here that should be
alright
yes you're right can you try to set the
width and height of the input video as
well the same way you do it up there
just for the input a video yeah no no
just copy duplicate right right below
them is yeah
no no right below right here
so here and now do it on the input video
instead of the output canvas so both are
set to the same size you know the input
video is the video element right try to
do it there yeah yes okay try that
it's okay yeah
so there are two lines of codes missing
I am very sorry I made that example up
here that you have to set the canvas bit
and hang I forgot to mention here you
have to do the same on the input video
element otherwise OpenCV will complain
and say your video is not the same as
your canvas so you have to do these two
lines for the input video as well you
can do it on the same spot sorry I
forgot that
oh it's black black why is it black what
happens o your own function oh you need
to do it this part in one specific
function that can call itself again
right you can do that outside whatever
you want there can say like processed
video or something Oh
yeah
exactly and then I can
you need to put that into here as well
the function right you have to exact
perfect
that's your work
yes there you go yeah yeah
okay where are you let me quickly see so
the width and the height you can get
from these settings settings has width
and height on it so maybe do all of
these things up here like until cap
reads like this whole block you don't
you only have to do once so you don't
need to do that and they can really
capture too you can do that up there
this one yeah so you only need this in
your actual function
yeah and then you can go for a setting
start with ya and settings tonight
exactly perfect okay so that looks good
now we just have to make sure that that
window requestanimationframe is inside
your function because you want at the
end when you are done right you want it
to be cold again cool try it
Oh doesn't allow you to do that okay
okay almost do we get an error message
nothing so can you show me the function
again
that looks good we have cells for
Charles this actually looks good
I don't see your issue see get back to
default yeah that's good with Heights
you're doing it the right way
huh
you can't currently see what issues any
real of the rats
huh
can you try it this is are you using
Chrome or Firefox
can you try anything Crump just for a
quick try not that it should it should
work for for Firefox as well just want
to make sure that this is not some weird
bug okay cool we are having an actual
error but I don't see it currently so
input video is the capture you have
video hide video wait settings with
something's I have to make rush you
huh no you don't have to do anything on
the HTML or you shouldn't shouldn't host
it
that looks all good
kappa source test
process already
you go down again like justice right so
you be color RGB a to gray oh oh it's to
grayscale I think isn't it can you check
under or did you copy it
this one no it's that one huh that's
weird
can you put it in my opinion you're
doing the right thing yeah I don't see
you later
and I can't really know that
unfortunately you see it in the browser
though if you go to the Patriot have it
open and you enter CV dealt color oh you
have to write it and small
RGBA
hmm
this is mute
I'll have to continue and there's a
branch if the solution we can then look
at it what is it what happens okay so I
hope most of you have gotten it to work
somehow I included a solutions branch so
if you check out the branch solution
grayscale it will do the code than you
need and it should work for you all so
what do you have to do oh this is a bit
small can you read that so good so what
you needed to do is I did the specific
pixel risk you could omit the pixel
because the browser is thinking that you
need pixels when you don't say anything
so there's pixel height and we set that
on the input video and the output canvas
we said it on the source object display
that I added in is basically for iOS
Safari because Safari is very
restrictive about how to apply auto
playing videos so you don't need that
specifically I added it in that it works
on most browsers then we have the matrix
settings as you seen them the video
captures set up and then we say go ahead
process video so what do you see here I
have a little I have added a little
something in iframe counter so you would
go with read converter color show and
then requestanimationframe again so
let's let's just look at it right um
let's go for localhost 8080 voila this
is how it should look like hello and you
see up here we are getting 60 frames per
second well 59 frames per second this is
what it should look like so that's a
very easy example I mean gray scaling
isn't supposed to take a lot of
processing power
but we can do something else that does
so let's look at that now let's go to
that oh yeah memory leaks we are in see
so we have a lot of gels with memory
leaks now since we start when the
webpage loads up and we end when the
webpage is closed we don't need to care
as much but usually all these objects
the matrices have a delete function on
them if you don't need them anymore you
would actually have to call delete
because yeah it's C right we have to
free memory it won't be garbage
collected yeah but in our example we
won't have to care about that as much so
let's come to the fun part right so we
have a stream we have open CV an open CV
can handle classifiers if you have been
at the talk yesterday I think it was
about classifiers that can detect is it
a cat or a dog we will use a classifier
that can detect is it a face or is it
not a face it's not the best classifier
so you will be able to fool it somehow
but it is an OK classifier so that's the
first thing we need classifier then we
need to run that classifier with each
frame we already have set up that loop
now right and if it didn't work for you
check out the solution branch then you
have dances that loop set up then we get
a vector which is basically an array
right so we can go through this vector
with faces and draw these as rectangles
on our video stream the classifier that
we're going to use is called har cascade
classifier that's a pre trained
classifier I haven't done that this is
from OpenCV they provide that that's
like a standard classifier for you to
choose so we don't have to train that
right we don't want to Train it to you
we don't
for now so we can just take that
pre-trained one then we load that it's
an XML and we give it to open CV you
don't have to do that because it's a bit
cumbersome we have to fetch it make a
byte array input into open CV I already
did that for you and I did it on a
branch called exercise face detection so
when you start this exercise checkout
exercise face detection so what we have
to care about now is we run the
classifier the classifier is designed to
run on a grayscale image so you already
know how that works but with the end
result let me show you the end result so
there's also a solution face detection
please don't go right there that won't
be fun
but we will do it now that you see what
we are trying to achieve at least so
let's go on there so here you see oh you
see there is actually up something up
there that looks oh he recognizes my
face over up here that's cool oh he's
not so sure
oh now he's pretty sure but this is also
a face so you see it's not the best face
detection algorithm but it's okay it's
okay
so we don't want this image to be
grayscale right that wouldn't be fun so
what we have to care for is that we have
a new matrix that is not grayscale
because that crazy can one we use for
the classifier so we will have a third
matrix that is just to show to the users
that is looking cool right that has all
four channels on it so we need to we
basically need a copy of our source
matrix for that so this is how we can
copy a matrix nothing very fancy around
here this matrix for the grayscale with
have to initialize with height and width
because we are not growing it going to
put it on the canvas or read it from the
camera so we will get the source matrix
in here and it will get the size of that
source matrix just inherently so this is
basically what we do instead of from
source to destination we go from that
copy its destination thing to gray that
new matrix that we just initialized up
here just one more matrix then we need
to instantiate a vector where our
algorithm will put the faces in so we
know what faces he found and this is how
the classifier is done wrong you can
look at the bottom this is where you see
how the classifier is accentuated but
it's a bit cumbersome so don't worry
about that we have to load the XML files
and everything so this is just a new
classifier with that XML file that we
just loaded detect multiscale so it will
scale the image and multiple factors and
try to see which faces are real faces on
all scaling factors so he is pretty sure
that this is a face the values down here
at the end here these are values that
probably people that have actual
experience in image processing can tell
you more about I don't know them very
well these are just like default values
to have a basic face detection algorithm
running so when we do that here you see
that we put in that faces vector after
this one run that face vector has faces
on it so we just need to look through
that lecture and paint these faces easy
as that this will look something like
this since this is a sea of check now
right that that vector is not a
JavaScript object
arrey you can't do that for each dot map
or dot filter so you have to do a
classical for loop over it get the size
with dot size and get the face with that
in the x-axis I face have four things on
it XY where it is and width and height
so we only have to draw a rectangle with
open CV this is called CV dot rectangle
this is how it will look like we draw it
on the destination matrix so we will
make a rectangle on the destination
matrix we need two points here I gave
you the code for a one point this is top
left how you get to the bottom right is
your exercise and this is the color RGB
a so this will be red you can do
whatever color you want to there one one
small notes I scaled down the inputs to
320 pixels this is where the algorithm
works best usually you wouldn't do that
visibly to the user
you would take the matrix scale it down
internally give it to the classifier and
then scale up the rectangles again and
put out the output destination matrix
would be full scale again so the user
has best possible resolution but this is
just more code so what I did is just I
cropped the whole inputs that's in the
input matrix to 320 pixels that's not
very nice but it is fast and performant
yeah so you can go to the exercise face
detection branch and try to get that up
and running
and you also can try to fiddle a bit
with parameters and colors and you can
also do circles if you want to draw a
circle around the face whatever you like
to if you want to check it out
I deployed the solution of the cloud so
we can go onto here and you can try it
out so you see what you should be aiming
for
yeah tell me
I do not miss men's their tightness
metal do yes
look yeah the problem is you try to read
the matrix here but you're setting the
width and height here so this is after
it reads so here it will throw an
exception because it has no width and
height
exactly that's can you go back to your
this is the problem you see you are
reading and while reading is as there is
no there is no size on it so you have to
do that I'm here somewhere
yeah
cool
here you need a dollar in front of the
yeah exactly
and they're too cool so this should work
oh wait wait a second can you go back
across this video where is the function
oh yeah you have to put this part into
that function right this is the one that
loops all the time you don't want to do
all that right all the time we just want
to do d3 so maybe make a new function
down here or something and put these in
no.11
yep exactly all this needs to be in
there
exactly
and put that in perfect and now we just
have to call it once from up here so
that it actually initializes the the
loop and this don't work Oh
Oh what did it say
huh
oh you mean because of caching I don't
think so that let's see again your code
I think there's just probably just
something very small a window that was
settings sorry
settings start with not window you have
to take the stream yeah I think I will
do the quest now because people are kind
of leaving already so we can get to
I already showed it huh well oh yeah I
can yeah and hop hop hop
Oh No where is it what does it say
kidding
I am sorry maybe
no no no you don't need to restart our
episode that's just a static web server
he does nothing
can you go into the main chairs quickly
if you go to sources oh yeah yeah this
is definitely the newest code right okay
so let's go back to the code we missed
one height or not one whistle infant
video iPod
oh yeah yeah up here it's with that
height copy/paste alright cool
so now it should work so reload and that
should work
here you go cool
so I see that already some of you are
leaving so before all of you are gone
there are two things I want to say we
will quickly look at the solution so you
can work on that on your own if you want
to and I will do a little quiz to get
some Swiss chocolate so the three best
ones will get oops a big chocolate so
let's quickly look at the solution just
brush over it very quickly so you see
the only change that we have to do is in
process video we will copy to that new
destination matrix we make that new
grayscale matrix then we run that
multiscale classifier and then we loop
over all phases the bottom right point
we can just say face dot X plus width
and face the Y plus height right so we
get the bottom right or from your point
of view the bottom right point that
makes more sense
and the rest is the same right we have
that rectangle and we still do image
show so if you checked it out I think we
are not getting the best frame rates
there are people that optimize this
better so if you look at it I think
before we that's weird so before we were
able to get up to 15 frames per seconds
sometimes yeah you see now 14 15 frames
per second not very good so if we would
be optimizing that thing and website
people did that you see we would get
they get 30 frames per second for web
assembly they did a comparison to us and
choice and native that's the same kind
of algorithm we are using just we are
not using it very optimized with just do
a very simple example
so if you do it with a some chairs
it is around 20 frames per second and
native JavaScript is at 2 frames so this
is where actually you native performance
makes a very big difference if you want
to be somewhere close to real-time or
something in that direction you should
totally go for web assembly in that
direction cool
yeah I think that's probably my sum up
of everything you don't need to use
webassembly to have minor road
improvements on your Chava script code
base or something like that where
assembly is meant to run heavy stuff so
use it for that don't use it to get your
angular app faster or something like
that that's not whatever it will be your
firm cool so all the resources we used
all the stuff we can read up on I mean
you have to link to my presentation now
yeah let's do a little bit Kristin the
end I think you have already seen that
there is this Kahoot thingy right so
go to cahoots Delta IT and enter that
pin and your name and then we can have a
fun little Chris and after that we will
be done okay we have naughty nicknames
oh okay okay cool
and ice
cool are we all is there somebody who
wants to shine we're all good
so get ready oh oh
I up with the logo sorry what's
the short form of webassembly
you have 10 seconds time the earlier you
click the more points you will be
rewarded ooh and think all already
answered that cool yeah and obviously
some might have clicked wrong right but
almost everybody knew that cool so we
have somebody in front Johnny I hope I
pronounced that right I'm sorry if I
didn't cool what's the next question
what was our IDE code that we used for
our basic examples
yeah I see way too easy questions for
you guys
way too easy all around okay there was
somebody was very advanced on that okay
move up to the next question how do we
tell the Russ compiler to not remove our
function
so easy questions I need that so easy
cool yeah Kahoot is still up from nice
let's go on to the next question what's
the name of the computer vision library
we used yes who's the fastest precedence
so somebody clicked wrong
Oh didn't take my clicker first so
Kahoot seems to be very fast at school
let's go to the last question how many
employee is the suka Singapore have
currently I mean there has to be one to
decide right so it is 34 is it 35 36 37
oh that's a nice curve there cool okay
that was a fun question for the end so
that we definitely have a kind of people
on top so congrats to these three people
come up front in the end you can collect
your Toblerone here I hope you have fun
during that workshop and that you like
webassembly now as much as I do and yeah
have a nice rest of the conference
[Applause]